au mieux c'est un beau spectacle mais le
14 juillet plusieurs fois par semaine
cela peut très vite lasser pour beaucoup
d'habitants de besançon c'est même
devenu un poison des nuits gâchée par
les détonations à 23 heures ça suffit
pour vous réveiller ouais c'est pas un
bruit un bruit sympathique d'un oiseau
qui chante donc ça devient pénible parce
que je pense qu'on aspire tout ça est
tranquille chez soi le phénomène
n'épargne aucun quartier le week-end
dernier encore plusieurs milliers
d'habitants ont entendu les mêmes
explosion ouais c'était le soir c'est
très dérangeant ben moi j'ai cru que
c'était un tremblement de terre s'était
trop fort en cherchant un peu on trouve
des reliques de feu d'artifice y compris
devant les murs d'enceinte de la maison
d'arrêt peut-être une façon de fêter
l'anniversaire de certains détenus mais
contrairement à d'autres villes besançon
n'a pas connu d'utilisation des tournées
des fusées pour ce cas pas de signature
particulière je crains fort qu'on soit
quelque chose de ludique
qui les amuse
un peu transgressif mais on n'a pas là
la signature de ce qui est souvent plus
grave c'est à dire une utilisation
contre les personnes pour ce
professionnel de la pyrotechnie il ne
s'agit pas de mortier mais d'un matériel
directement achetés sur internet comme
celui ci pour une quarantaine d'euros on
est sur une pièce via il ya 40 49 coup
un qui vont partir sur environ 25
secondes donc forcément c'est très
intense c'est des effets qui monte à peu
près à 22 25 mètres d'altitude donc oui
ça peut faire du bruit jusqu'ici aucun
accident n'a été enregistré mais il ya
toujours un risque à manipuler des feux
d'artifice si celui ci un petit peu mon
cas je viens y vient à peiné sur leur
sur le côté là ça peut être une
catastrophe pour toute personne qui se
trouve à proximité
l'acquisition et l'utilisation de feux
d'artifices réservé aux professionnels
peut être puni d'un an d'emprisonnement
et 15 mille euros d'amande